hey guys how's it going it's Justine
today I'm joining Armando how are you
I'm doing great how about yourself I'm
doing awesome and I'm so glad that
you're here I've been doing a bunch of
videos talking about the new MacBook I
also mentioned that I needed a friend
the new premier and guess what he's here
over here so thank you for inviting me
by the way yes thanks for coming this is
so exciting you know there's been a lot
of drama going on about the i9
throttling but Apple did come out with
an update and a patch so it was a
software thing not a hardware issue
which was exciting for all of us who
bought the i9 MacBooks I stopped to buy
mine yeah well that's okay cuz guess
what we've got one got one absolutely
incredible that's nice
what did you bring today for us to test
out I brought cooling pads I figured
okay so I went on Amazon or started
doing research and I found out that a
lot of people like these things in fact
if you go on Amazon right now thousands
of people are giving this these five
stars I'm gonna be honest with you I
don't believe this is going to help in
any way you don't think so I don't think
so what do you think why not they're
fans blowing air into your computer and
it's being elevated so I think it has to
help a little bit I don't know we're
gonna debunk that myth and that's why
I'm here and we're gonna be testing this
out in premiere because that is the most
taxing on the system I do want to try a
Final Cut export to see if any of these
would help out the export that I had
been testing previously so I don't know
we'll see whichever one does the best in
premier we'll test it in Final Cut so
let's do that let's go ahead and do a
baseline run first to see what it does
by the way we are in controlled
environment very nice temperature you
have here's normally I turn the air
conditioning off but we're gonna keep it
on so that's I think it's like 72 that's
nice nice 72 yes let's do it
okay cool ready 1 2 3 YouTube 2160p 4k
we are going to start in 3 2 1 go okay
it's estimating see how it fluctuates so
what is what's this project like what is
the shot on ok so yeah so this project
is a 7 f excuse me a 7 3 footage I shot
this in s log 3 it has a simple grade
and it's a fight I want to see 5 minutes
I guess we'll look right now I think
it's
five minute clip so in between each of
our little tests here we're gonna have
either a story or some medical facts but
you can tell the story I'll tell you
sorry of franconi
so I had a friend who was relatively
close with like Apple Steve Jobs and all
that he tells me a lot of stories so
when Apple and Google were still friends
the Google logo was off by a little bit
and Steve Jobs was so mad that he'd like
basically called or email them and said
you need to fix the Google logo so that
the pixels are perfect that's how
meticulous the job was that he wanted
everything to look good on the iPhone oh
man okay so I just found my FLIR one and
this connects to your phone so you can
see how hot your computer is running we
have to do for the other ones that's
gonna be great the cooling pad will see
where it's performing and that's gonna
be good so there is 60 seconds remaining
we're almost at 10 minutes it's a long
time that's a long time for a five
minute exporter so here's the question
that I have for you why aren't you using
Final Cut
I shouldn't raw and Final Cut Pro does
not support it doesn't feed me let me
rephrase that because there's gonna be
people look are loaded my friends does
not support Canon drawlight the values
to edit the raw file you can you can
play back oh it's done I would say 10 34
so 10 34 for the baseline and so let's
go ahead and write that down
oh that is sweet this is our first test
baseline test so while we unbox this it
gives the laptop a little bit of time to
kind of cool itself because right now we
just checked and it's pretty hot it is
yeah this is the first one I grabbed oh
I'm so excited
I'll let you do the honors all right
let's put you off to the side you're a
little friends we need a knife
sure pastor do you wanna know so this is
a nice kitchen knife this is actually
one of my favorite ones though this is
the hot my favorite
I will not mess with it you can use
these for yeah go ahead
this is our first ones who makes us
honest tration free yeah I don't know
about that
I'm not really sure there's room I don't
even know who maces okay
raishin free I'm slightly frustrated
TechNet tech it looks interesting
looks industrial so this looks like it
just has two giant fans on an off switch
USB oh very nice I never read
instructions
I don't either there's misuse yeah
pretty
I think self-explanatory and pretty
question is I don't want to hear the
question cuz I know where do we put it
let me get a jump ring the dongle we're
good I think it's our long whoa RGB Wow
look at these lights
I don't know see this is what I'm
talking about there's no way I mean come
on it's not gonna make it worse very
true or will it make it worse because
now sucking a bit of power from your
computer to power that's it you know
what that is really that's a good theory
are we ready to do this I think we are
so this is our second test using the
TechNet cooling pad whatever this thing
is on three two one go
X morning how much faster do you think
it's going to render I don't really have
a lot of experience with premiere so I
feel like I don't really know at all I
mean I would say maybe it is like
seconds I can't imagine it would be
minutes because that would be crazy
do you have any Apple facts this isn't a
fact but there is one of the biggest
private collections of Apple gear
products everything in Prague it's
called the Apple Museum and it is the
most fantastic place that I ever
accidentally came across I was in Prague
and I was like I'm gonna come if they
have an Apple store here googled Apple
Store Apple Museum showed up and it is
beautiful he even has a Steve Jobs shirt
like it definitely goes that route but
those really cool spheres are problems
definitely check it out I want to go now
I actually want to go back because I
only had a little bit of time and I want
to spend more time back that's really
neat I'll hit the stop here real quick
24:23 it's gonna be really close oh no
way what 10:30 wait I don't know why I'm
upset because I definitely said it was
going to make a difference for seconds
TechNet we can't say it didn't work
basically like four seconds right right
understand that Premiere Pro is it just
taxes the cpu this test in final cut
could render different results plus I
have another one you're for you let this
one off to the side that was technical
stuff guys okay so when you showed me
some of these that you're ordering this
is crazy because I don't know if you
remember but a long long time ago I used
to have a bamboo desk and I had this you
know what I never ever plugged it in I
just used it as a bulb it looked nice
yeah it's cool tell me all about it you
probably know more yeah we just plugged
it in we're gonna wait a couple minutes
for it to cool and then we'll run the
test again this is much longer this is
much long yeah I'm sure
on three okay yep three two one go
now this is not an apple but what is
the most unique item from Apple that you
own it's still in a box right now and I
haven't opened it yet really it is in
1984 original it's the 128k 1984 Mac I'm
waiting to do the video it's still in
the box and just keep thinking about it
just waiting for the moment so soon okay
it'll happen
nice what about you I have a mousepad oh
yes that's so cool we are at the 1
minute 30 second mark
so this is our bamboo this looks hotter
I think because those that air is being
blown up like that yeah so these are the
fans right here and you can see the heat
is now blowing up no way is it better
10:24 I'm just puzzled how this is much
smaller like the fans but here's the
thing it's much louder it is much louder
so your fans may be running a little bit
faster and also this is wood so I don't
know if the wood is maybe drawing some
of these out of it well nothing lift it
up I'll show them
this little pattern design yeah like you
said you're right you're absolutely
right it's dissipating or it's sucking
all that heat into the wood now here's a
gaming one how would you pronounce that
newbie bird no bird that is crazy lucky
nope no bird no no oh this is looks like
it would be made for a 17 inch plastic
whoa look at the braided cable it kind
of has this nice almost like a bevel
yeah that was nice like a mesh it almost
looks like something Republic of gamers
would make like an rog oh my gosh I have
one of those masts it was like 17 inch
one that thing was so incredibly loud
but was so powerful this about this Oh
fan controls Oh we've always got to turn
it up to the X so this definitely can
hold a 17 inch computer because this is
huge
this feels a lot cooler yeah I am going
to say this one is probably gonna do
pretty good I'm hoping now I think so
and because it also is extending over
the sides too and there's this is gonna
be interesting
three two one go I didn't think any of
these were gonna work I just keep saying
like it definitely makes sense because
it is slightly elevated Pro check the
thermals what are you looking when
you've got like a while at 120 121 I
mean it's basically about the same so
244 no so it was the same this was this
is one of those that it looks like it's
going to do great this is metal so
that's actually heating up hmm
this one is so far the worst which I
actually thought this would be yeah me
too I thought for sure this is gonna be
better look at this guys this is super
fancy so this looks very similar Oh
another six fan Oh metal smaller fans
the bamboo has a smallest man which are
almost equal is this this is the first
one that has something that will make
sure your laptop doesn't fall off yep
and you just lift this up like this it
feels very flimsy like it's going to
break does feel like it's gonna break
this is an aggressive stand the fans
seem very low like I don't really hear
them very much you know it's quiet three
two one go
and now we wait so we're having the same
sort of effect with the heat pattern
kind of flowing up on the corners there
time 10:41 1041 okay 41 so not the worst
shoot yeah bummer so I'm not a few fans
it reminds me of like those trekker fans
you know the one that they use yes how
many stars yeah I didn't look
what if this ends up being the best no
fan control this one I think you just
you're just gonna get you're asking for
a lot look at that
what does it say to you you can program
it but I'm not sure how I didn't read
the direction we'll just let it just
show you thank you guys
are you ready I am ready okay on three
two one go
alright let's wait and see
what do you guys think better or worse
you'll find out very shortly wait dude
we've been doing Apple facts Apple
faster crap effects or story story so
this is actually a really fun story that
will be in an upcoming video so this is
actually having back in May I went to it
was the MoMA in San Francisco I was
looking at one of these sketches it was
above the original Mouse like the design
that then became a mouse and I was like
wow this is so cool and I met this guy
there and he went to the museum to see
his sketch it was the guy that made the
sketch in 1983 it was so you happened to
be there at the right time it was like
I'm actually getting goosebumps just
like thinking about it because it was
just the craziest time ever and he was
like telling me all these really cool
stories about like Apple and Steve Jobs
that I'm not gonna share but it was such
an incredible moment that is awesome I
was like are you sure he like got out
his ID and showed me because I didn't
believe in like would you say well no no
way no way incredible in most of the
other tests you guys might remember that
the heat was flowing upwards where now
it's kind of concentrated more down
right yeah and I'm gonna say 1036 it was
just ramping real quick yeah well we got
one more to go guys my science
experiment has failed look what we have
here oh boy this one looks really
aggressive and it's designed
encapsulating China okay well either way
it looks very scary
well oh yeah probably is rushing towards
us but whoa the new being the new be
like like but newbies do you think it's
even gonna rank
see I just I think the reason that
bamboo one did so well is because it
wasn't basically acting like a skillet
yeah like this metal is heating up and
it was completely defeating the purpose
or the spits of ice this is one of the
nicer fitting ones but okay good it goes
with this skin whenever they launched
this black camo the dbrand
I was freaking out because I feel like
every tech reviewer had it on their
phone or their laptops no like this is
so great so now I have one on mine too
and I'm so excited so huge thank you
daddy brand for sponsoring this video
link in the description if you guys want
to check it out I've been such a fan of
theirs for so long they make good stuff
I know so thank you guys I love it I'm
gonna have a dbrand desktop we were
talking about how cool would it be to
get this all by mean there's so many
different colors I could just send them
the dimensions the show dear Anne oh my
gosh I want a marble top oh that would
look good the marble one that they have
I saw everybody has those as well
concrete oh this is oh my gosh I have so
many ideas I forgot we were even doing
okay okay it's still loud but it's not
obnoxious seems comparable to the
previous one that we did I still think
the worst one was the bamboo and that so
far is our winner yeah it makes sense
three two one go I'm excited this is our
last one do you have a nap in fact I do
I have a really good Apple fact actually
okay so I'm not sure if this is true or
not but I heard the story by law here in
California you don't have to put a
license plate on your car for six months
meaning that for six months you're okay
if you get pulled over like it's fine
like they give you that grace period so
Steve Jobs had an agreement with the
dealership every six months he would
least he would renew his lease so he
never had to put a front license plate
actually any not front or just license
plate period that is so good no like to
even like think of that but it shows
like Steve's character as a rebel you
know I mean like I'm not gonna abide by
your rules because but he still was
abiding by the rules because he was
reloading every six months legally so
technically he was abiding by the rules
but just finding the loopholes exactly
that was that was in did you know that
my I did not actually but I have googled
his car before because I once saw
somebody that did have a license plate
that said like STV jobs and that see
jobs
so this is our last test this is the
killer baby instinct - whatever I'm sure
you're about 98 and I didn't so I'm not
sick that's good you look good
seems like these gaming ones are just
more hype than anything it's this metal
yeah you're cooking your laptop
10:42 oh gosh this is the worst one
Killer Bee has killed oh wait 10:57 can
just randomly stop like we're done now
Final Cut Pro oh yes okay so where did
you final cut on the bamboo the bamboo
we're gonna get a baseline first and
then what we'll do is after we have our
number cuz this is with the update yes
look like update with the update time to
try the export sources so we're gonna
try this now what are we even doing here
what is the meaning of computer life oh
I didn't see when it finished it doesn't
even matter
we don't really gonna say it was like
1315 without bamboo or a surge that is
probably the fastest that that exported
it previously was 1303
dongle okay here we go we are off to the
races
Oh again I didn't know what we're hoping
for
I don't know are we hoping that it wins
I'm not sure I don't know exactly I
don't even know do we want it to win do
we want it to succeed what do you think
I don't know will this change computing
forever no it's just five guys we're
just trying to see if this is even gonna
make a difference almost 10 its 950 but
it's I don't see a change oh wow
here it is that is all tool I think of
luke 2007 it even has like the little
button you have to push to unlock
the battery is dead but I did get a
charger for it and all of my old youtube
videos they're all in here like I used
to make videos with his eyesight like
that's what I film my first few videos
on let's get the knife out of the way
okay what's the time a 13 17 yeah so
check this out Justine and I actually
ran mmm a couple of tests behind the
scenes and they will always fluctuate a
little bit yeah
conclusion time I think the conclusion
that I've at least come to you is it
doesn't really make that much of a
difference so if this is something that
you're gonna get it is more sort of an
aesthetic thing if it is something that
you're putting on your lap maybe it'll
potentially make difference but all in
all the results that I saw is not enough
to make me go out of buy one of these no
and I think also another thing is how
well Final Cut Pro is optimized so that
it doesn't matter the variation of
temperature it's just gonna run optimal
no matter what that's probably why you
saw a little bit better gains in
premiere just because it did you know it
was a lot cooler than it was with five
cuts so I think that's another thing too
that you know that you could I guess
take away from this video and I think
we've I'm not switching houses anything
we've already established that for beer
definitely is not entirely optimized for
mac so that is something that I've heard
that Adobe is working on so hopefully
they need you please but I'll be over
here in Final Cut just chillin cuz it's
like cooler I got it oh I'm not very
funny anyway thank you guys for watching
we had so much fun doing this test thank
you on my channel make sure you guys go
check out his channel I've actually I
remember finding your videos years ago
like looking for how to color Greg's I'm
not very good at it and I was like I
wish you've had some final cut but I get
down low I guess it'll still grow both
ways I guess right so that I do have
some buds coming soon
really I want you to test them out let's
get crazy thank you again make sure you
go check out this channel he has tons of
really great tech videos lots of color
grading stuff and if you guys are from
your fans then you should probably go
over there come on guys check it out
thank you so much make sure to subscribe
I will see you later thank you success
[Music]